pour rélations saviez vous que la
consommation de fromage varie de la même
manière que le nombre de personnes qui
meurent en mêlée dans leurs bras saviez
vous que le nombre de fautes à une
dictée par des élèves âgés de 6 à 12 ans
varie en même temps que leur pointu
manger du fromage avant d'aller au lit
et il donne dangereux et faut-il avoir
de grands pieds pour être bon en
orthographe
ces relations entre des variables sont
des corrélations une corrélation et
l'évolution simultanée de deux variables
dans le même sens ou dans un sens
inverse toutefois il ne faut pas
confondre corrélation et causalité les
deux variables ne sont pas forcément
liées directement une troisième variable
peut être la cause de deux autres l'âge
est à la fois la cause de la pointure
des élèves mais aussi du nombre de
fautes à une dictée il n'y a donc aucun
lien de causalité directe entre la
pointure et la dictée il s'agit juste
d'une corrélation qui sera dans certains
cas due au seul hasard alors aux rêves
ou encore manger du fromage avant
d'aller au lit
[Musique]